welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on what it takes to
conquer most of the world before your
mid-30s with the help of a heart
devouring god of course you can't do it
alone you really can't
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt and i must say i'm
well behind the curve for conquering the
world oh boy seriously uh i'm turning 30
uh it next month in may so like i i need
to get it i don't have time we still
have time to conquer the world
soon it'll all happen soon anyway what's
our big question for today brandon okay
mt in the most recent episode of moon
night and boy what an episode it was our
guy steven grant he got his bootleg
indiana jones on and appeared to
discover the tomb of one of amit's
avatar and what a tomb it turned out to
be
bougie tomb oh that was a boujee tomb i
mean
if i gotta go i wanna go like that you
know what i mean that's right but this
this mummy that steven defiles uh turns
out to be none other than alexander the
great you've heard of him i've heard of
him pretty great i get that reference i
understood that reference but did this
powerful king of macedonia have a god to
thank for all of his renowned exploits
it all leads us to this week's big
question was alexander great because of
vomit
ooh
that is a really great question brandon
but let us take a look at some of the
major accomplishments of alexander iii
of macedonia to see what makes him the
great and then we can see if the power
of amit could have helped him accomplish
these feats to give him that god-like
status that many of his followers
believed that he had so of course
alexander the great was born on the 20th
or 21st of july in 356 bce the same year
as a larry king i'm sorry
king jokes
while he's down come on seriously he's
already god i'm sorry larry king empty
had a pile of larry king jokes he's like
i can't wait for this
i'm gonna roast his ass i thought he was
gonna live forever brandon i had too
many jokes
that dude was the same age forever so
yeah he was born on the 20th or 21st of
july in 356 bce in the city of pella in
macedonia that's pella right mt there's
gonna be a lot of words that none of us
know how to pronounce in this here we go
alexander was the son of philip ii king
of macedonia and his fourth wife
olympias listen it's always good to have
you know multiple wives because women
are smarter than men so like you know
men can't do it really you really pulled
out of that nose dive empty
jesus
and she's like here's why you got to
have 13 wives cut me out of this episode
[Music]
and he's
but yeah but one of the earliest legends
of alexander occurs when he's just 10
years old and a traitor brought a horse
to king philip that he wanted to sell
for a fair amount of gold however nobody
seemed to be able to actually mount this
wild horse so the king was ready to send
the horse away when alexander noticed
the horse was afraid of his own shadow
and he convinced his dad to let him try
riding it and then face the horse
towards the sun so it couldn't see its
shadow then alexander successfully
mounted the horse and his father was
quite depressed and stated my boy you
must find a kingdom big enough for your
ambitions macedon is too small for you
you rid this horse like a boss then
alexander kept this horse and named it
bucephalus and wrote it throughout his
conquest all the way to india where it
died at the age of 30. and then named
one of his cities he founded in india
after his horse kind of weird and messed
up
it's weird but like
it's a big flex i think and like he
really loves this horse and like
i do like this story about like a 10
year old alexander like figuring out the
the way to ride this horse it's also
ballsy of this guy to like bring a horse
to the king that no one can ride and be
like i want to sell you this horse it
doesn't do the one thing you needed to
do but i'm going to sell it to you your
highness right and i'm asking for a lot
of money for it
like i feel like if i was the king i'd
be like yeah kill this man he's trying
to get me killed um obviously he does
not want me to survive battle it's also
uh
alexander like loves naming cities after
himself all over his conquest he would
name like alexander of this alexandria
of that uh but i do love that like his
horse dies and he's like i'm gonna name
this city after my horse and all the
people living there are like hey we
already had a name for this dude
you got a whole name and culture don't
make me kill all you [ __ ] my horse
died i love my horse that horse saw a
lot of [ __ ] that horse saw something
yeah some intense fighting let's jump
back to when alexander was 13 and gets a
new tutor by the name of aristotle ever
heard of that man aristotle yes oh yeah
that aristotle the greek philosopher and
polymath who studied under plato and he
became alexander's teacher along with a
lot of his future generals and taught
them about medicine philosophy morals
religion logic dungeons and dragons and
art and he also gave alexander a copy of
the iliad which he would carry with them
throughout his life reportedly keeping
it under his pillow i love this part of
this story right like he hears the tale
of the iliad from aristotle and at this
point they're writing it down it's like
his comic book right he takes this he's
like yeah i love i love this story of
like these conquering heroes i'm gonna
keep it with me and like take it all
over and i guess uh aristotle had like
annotated it like wrote notes in it for
him so like this was like his thing he's
like yeah i'm i'm the alien man i'm troy
i'm taking it all i'm you know
i'm the badass i do like that too
because like when i was a kid like i
used to love reading the iliad and the
odyssey like at school because like it
felt like i was reading a superhero book
like and i've been hacking the system
like oh my god i'm just i'm learning but
also reading a cool the superhero story
over there yeah yeah well it gets like
presented as like history and so you're
like especially to alexander it's
presented as like hey these are the
facts of what happened there's this guy
achilles and he's blessed by the gods
and he's like a badass and alexander's
like hell yeah that's me dude let's go
when they get to the site of like troy
he's like he's blown away he's like oh i
read about this place this is awesome
this is just like my boog oh my god
but yeah in 336 bce when alexander was
20 years old his father king philip was
assassinated at his daughter's wedding
so rude by the captain of his bodyguards
even ruder some would say that alexander
immediately ascended to the throne and
became the king of macedonia and he
quickly consolidated his power by
assassinating those who he thought might
also have a claim to the throne
including other macedonian princes and
his own cousin which
like that must be really awkward at the
family get-together it's like oh my god
what's going on so young blood oh i
remember when you killed my son
your your your cousin it's a
very nice thing for you to do but it's
okay
you're still great in my eyes
well he's the king now you you have to
agree with it you have to be like after
you really smart thank you for killing
my son uh super great like we're going
to go grab any kids
some shish kebabs and i'll be right back
and thus he would begin his career of
conquest that would make him known as
the great and he didn't waste any time
invading the largest empire at the time
the akhmanian empire otherwise known as
the persian empire and he quickly
assumed territory of the balkans syria
gaza and asia minor but what matters
most in our discussion here today is his
arrival in egypt because that would make
the most sense of when he would come
into contact with ahmet and become her
avatar the last airbender just kidding
just regular avatar and alexander first
came to egypt in 332 bce and egypt was
still under persian control at the time
as the ancient egyptian empire had
declined way back in the 7th century bce
and the egyptians didn't really like
their persian rulers so they saw
alexander as a liberator and to
legitimize his rule alexander made
sacrifices at a temple in memphis and
consulted with the oracle of amun ra at
the s
let's say siwa like jojo siwa is it siwa
i think it's
the oracle of aman
siwa oasis and he was declared to be the
new master of the universe and the son
of the god amon and alexander himself
would continue to say for the rest of
his life that his true father was zeus
amman which is
kind of crazy like wow what a life what
basically combines like the greek god
and the egyptian god is in like one god
right
he was kind of smart he was like we have
different religions but it's all kind of
the same as a bunch of gods
sun moon stars all that blah blah blah
i'm this i'm the i'm the son of the he
basically said like my real dad my earth
dad he's not my real dad uh my real dad
is the big man upstairs
[Laughter]
the big man upstairs merged with the
other big man upstairs to make a bigger
man upstairs
the biggest man upstairs if the greeks
come calling he pops on like the white
beard and the lightning bolt he's like
hey yeah i'm zeus and then if the
egyptians pray is like hold on hold on
let me get a little headdress here let
me get a little eagle head okay now i'm
your god let's go yo honestly like
that's sort of what alex the great did
he was sort of just like he literally
adopted that egyptian culture he's like
listen he loved pharaoh i loved it yeah
yeah he loved that [ __ ] man he was a
like a weeb for egypt that's a great
comparison he got there and he was like
i love this [ __ ] this is great a weeb
egypt weeb egypt anyway and he was only
in egypt for a short amount of time as
he would go on to leave in 331 bce and
never return so not that much of a weeb
but his rule over egypt was widely
embraced by the people and while he did
install a greek style of government he
still respected egyptian culture
building new temples and monuments to
the egyptian gods even though he did in
that city after his horse no that was in
india that wasn't in that wasn't india
that wasn't india so that's not in egypt
so never mind
he respected the egyptians a lot more
than you respected him oh he did and he
also founded a new greek capital on the
nile called alexandria
where did he come up with that title who
knows uh he came up to him in a dream um
which would go on to have a well-known
library that would be burned to the
ground
and a lot of people are upset about that
well i mean that that happens in like
the 1300s right and they they credit the
event with the burning of the libraries
of alexandria to like setting human
knowledge back hundreds of years because
like all the collective knowledge from
around the world have been gathered in
alexandria
yeah i mean
you know like you said uh alexander was
not in egypt for a long time he had to
go off and conquer the world he couldn't
stay but he like loved the place and
like the egyptians really liked him and
one thing that there was like a story of
when you know his mama olympias was like
pregnant she there's a couple versions
of it but like she had a dream
essentially where her like womb was like
struck by lightning and it spread like
fire or something like that and so this
was meant to be that like there was this
theory that alexander was
you know
put into his mother's womb by zeus you
know what i mean very christ-like right
he's implanted there by god so this idea
that he calls himself zeus amen or the
son of zeus amen means like yeah i've
always been you know a progeny of a god
and so he comes to egypt you know he
makes these sacrifices out of temple and
memphis or in cy oasis and like he loves
it he loves everything about it he's
like i'm gonna get you people out of
persian control because you don't like
them you're paying a lot of taxes to
them i mean i'm still gonna charge your
taxes but it's okay uh
and yeah like like you said he puts all
these people in the government that are
greek but like they get along and they
they
they blend with the culture that's
already there so the egyptians really
liked this guy they put him on his
coinage you know he was like their
pharaoh essentially but even when he
wasn't there and yeah so if he meets
ahmet right in in the marvel sense of
this all this would make sense if he
goes to this temple and he's making
these sacrifices maybe ahmet comes to
him is like hey you and me we're going
to conquer the world buddy i'm going to
use you as my avatar hey stick with me
bud you seem pretty cool
want this power to murder let's talk
about one of alexander's legendary feats
mt was it the right one or the left one
uh his right foot i think was more
legendary than his left foot if i
believe you heard that here first uh
tarantino fans
tarantino loves alexander's feet i don't
know if we see his feet in the alexander
movie i don't i don't know we see a lot
of the alexander movie check the wiki
why did you make me do this one of
alexander's legendary feats was the
undoing of the gordian knot okay
so when he was conquering parts of what
is now turkey he arrived in the
philippian capital of gordium okay and
there was this legend there when the
city was first founded
that the first person to arrive in town
on an ox cart would become its king okay
and a peasant named gordius did just
that he becomes the king they named the
city gordium uh and he ties his ox cart
to a pole and he dedicates his ox cart
to zeus right because he was part of the
prophecy the knot that ties this cart to
this pole was made of cornell bark uh
which would harden over time and so they
had this whole legend that who said who
who could ever undo this intricate knot
would conquer all of asia right it's
this one it's this prophecy on top of a
prophecy so alexander he's fighting his
way across the area and he rolls into
this town and he comes across this
puzzle uh and he simply he just like
pulls out his sword and he cuts the knot
apart and he claims i did it i fixed i
undid the not right
the prophecy is true his claim was that
like it didn't it didn't matter how the
knot was undone just that it got
loosened and this this is part of the
legend today right uh the term gordian
knot or like solvent 40 or not the idea
of
approaching up a problem with like a out
of the box solution right he didn't
bother trying to undo the knot because
there were no loose ends or anything
like that he's just like i'll take it
and i'll cut it boom knots undone so the
question is did ahmet help with this
feat this is one of his legendary feats
the only problem is this happens before
he gets to egypt it's on his way to
egypt his roundabout way to egypt that
this event happened so while this is one
of his great events right i don't think
ahmed helps with this one but maybe this
proves why he's he's meant to be the
avatar for ahmed what's really
interesting here is that this sort of
like obviously parallels the the whole
steve rogers moment in captain america
one when um you know he has to go get
the the flag at the top of the um pole
and he's like right whoever can grab
that flag can ride in the truck and then
steve rogers like i'm just gonna
freaking take this flag down literally
and grab them well you see all that you
see all those boys those muscle boys try
so hard to climb the ball and they're
slipping and they're sliding you're
right empty that's a great example of
like a gordian knot situation you have a
problem and you have a non-typical
solution to solve that problem you think
outside the box exactly and so like in
later on we see that that steve rogers
himself is worthy of you know being
captain american and of course where the
wheeling thor's hair and down the line
so like hey maybe like this like gordian
experience like you said is what what
made i would be like um this is
interesting of a smart thinking man i'm
about to free my people
and if you believe that like the gordian
knot is a test from zeus himself or a
god and he's able to defeat this test
maybe ahmed notices that and is like
okay this guy's a great candidate maybe
she starts influencing him to come to
egypt like whispering to him like it was
come help free egypt right because
remember we know that the the anion is
pissed because you know they're not
being worshipped anymore and that's why
they left that's what they said on the
show right they leave
uh egypt because they're not respected
anymore they're not they're not happy
you know they're not being worshipped by
the people they're not getting hyped up
by their boys anymore yeah yeah the
persians are taking over and the enid's
like screw you guys we're out of here
you're on your own hey look at me
[ __ ]
[Music]
but ahmet's like no i want to get my
kingdom back i want to get egypt back
for the people she sees what this
alexander boy is up to and she's like
i'm going to influence him to come to
egypt so i can get into his body and
give him power let me see that body
let me see those feet let me see those
feet alexander
let me see that right foot that's a
great foot that's a good foot
ahmed had a foot fetish confirmed she's
got all those different feet she's got
like lion feet she's got hippo feet she
loves feet she she's a whole puzzle of a
woman that helmet um
very thick um not as thick as the real
hippo woman that we saw at the end which
is the ultimate thickness oh my god oh i
thought miss minutes was still oh my god
if i joke about this that's how this
thing started i mean you really live the
gimmick empty you really love the
gimmick i really do
um but hey let's talk about the defeat
of the persian empire next because not
long after you left egypt alexander was
able to defeat the persian empire and
solidify his role of his vastly growing
empire and the definitive moment in this
campaign came when he faced the persian
emperor darius iii and his 200 000 men
holy moly it's a big army alexander had
only 47 000 men at his disposal which is
like 157
plus
thousands more men
which is kind of crazy um but still
attacked the vastly larger enemy which
is consisted of calvary wearing chain
mail chariots with blades sticking out
of the wheels which is very hardcore and
i should probably install that this is
very much like grease
this is very much like you know what we
know in like 300 right this isn't xerxes
obviously this is darius iii but the
persian army at the time was still huge
and still very powerful and had all
these crazy weapons uh and yeah they
really outnumbered alexander here but he
went in on them he wasn't afraid and
they defeated the larger army and darius
was killed by one of his own men while
escaping on horseback because
you know she that's a really a coward's
move and uh that dude was not having and
after this alexander was named king of
asia and he took babylon and persophilus
under his control and actually started
dressing like a persian and married a
persian dancer to try and appeal to this
newly conquered people but some of his
own men didn't like this behavior and
found it unbecoming of a conqueror which
you know doesn't really make sense
considering that like if you're going to
be a conqueror wouldn't you want your
people to like you because like like you
like like i said earlier with egypt like
people loved him well that's the thing
he's trying to appeal to the persians
right uh and his own men who were greek
and macedonian by
you know original descent they were kind
of like why are you doing this like
you're a conqueror you don't need to
appeal to these people but yeah he
married this dancer named roxanne uh and
maybe he just really liked her maybe he
liked how like the persian aristocracy
dressed and he was like into it he also
was very much like he would come into
towns yes he did they did a lot of
killing a lot of murdering a lot of bad
stuff i mean i like killing light
killings
yeah i mean we're talking like you know
third century bce like this is heavy
stuff but he is like on the nicer side
of the killing and conquering i don't
know how to say that but like he very
much wasn't like he would come to town
and he'd be like look you're part of us
now you're part of macedonia you're part
of my empire but you know you're gonna
do our system in government you're gonna
pay taxes to us but like you keep doing
your thing you keep your city running i
like what you got going on here i'm just
here to like
you know build an empire that's what i'm
trying to do
i think that pretty much sums it up but
this is like an instance and
mt that makes a lot of sense if
of him being ahmed's avatar right the
ability to destroy this huge army eating
all of these hearts taking all of these
souls
i mean he's got to have the power of a
god behind him right this is crazy stuff
because we don't really get have an idea
of what ahmet did to cause her to be in
prison in the first place
so well if we believe what arthur harrow
is saying right that ahmed is here to
stop the bad guys the hitlers the pol
pots if like darius iii the you know the
leader of persia at the time is like a
terrible person then ahmed's like yeah
we got to get this guy out of here like
maybe alexander is doing bad things too
but he's the lesser evil like as long as
he takes control these people will be
safe one thing i thought was interesting
is bringing up babylon right because we
know that the eternals were in babylon
in part of like history i feel like this
would make sense as to why
the gods imprisoned on it to begin with
because like maybe it was alexander in
his whole
like murder campaign of like you know
conquering all these people that the
gods were all like hey
maybe one man like kanye west said
wasn't meant to have all this power
no one man should have all this power
they don't interfere because there's no
deviance involved right they were only
in fighting in babylon to protect the
city from the deviants
but but in this instance it's like as
long as alexander's not riding on a
bunch of deviants backs or something
like that he's going to do what he's
going to do and we're going to stay out
of the way they also primed these people
for being like hey there's going to be
people coming from other lands you got
to let them in you got to like be a part
of their culture like take it into yours
so i love to think of the eternals like
sitting back and being like this guy is
really
he's doing a good job do you think he's
got a god behind him i don't know maybe
are the eternals aware of like the gods
and stuff i mean they're aware of thor
they knew thor so like surely they're
aware of these egyptian gods i feel like
the the eternals have to be aware of the
gods some to some degree because the the
gods have to have factored into the
celestial's plans i feel like odin is
the janitor of the universe that was
appointed by this yeah before i like
that yeah and um you know i think that
because like you you the the gods have
to see all the celestial stuff happening
in the world in the universe and like
they have to sort of be okaying this in
in some sort of way so like i definitely
feel like the eternals
have some type of knowledge of the god
and we know that um it sort of hinted in
eternals that veena had this history as
being like athena like this goddess of
war figure right so like i feel like
fina at least knew alexander the great
that's a great point empty yeah she's
probably like oh he's rolling he's
rolling into persopolis i'm going to
jump in on this fight just for a little
bit just for a little bit guys i'll be
back
okay empty so like you said
alexander is now the king of asia so he
wants to make sure he sees all of asia
right
uh so he started moving into india and
like further in into india because at
the time it was believed that the end of
asia was just on the eastern border of
india which spoiler alert it's not uh it
goes much further than that uh but they
didn't know that at the time like
they're they thought like he thought the
end of india was like the end of asia
and he's like well i'm the king of asia
so i'm gonna check it out so he's
pushing his men to go further and
further
um and he's able he's actually able to
defeat the king of india porus uh and
his army which included like war
elephants which is the most badass thing
you can think of
was porous stabbed because then that
means porous was very porous at the end
of his life
oh boy
sorry boris kicking both porus and larry
king
no one's safe when mt's
so yeah he beats he beats porus and they
defeat these elephants but like they
keep going and it it soon becomes very
clear that asia is much bigger than they
thought it was uh and his men are like
tired of marching and fighting and
they're so far away from home in
macedonia that they kind of like rebel
and he's like okay okay we'll go back
we'll go back
so they start they start heading back
but he wants to go the long way like
alexander wants to go south down india
go to the coast and then kind of like
sail along the coastline to get back to
persia where in babylon and stuff like
that uh and this was a horrible idea um
because he winds up losing 15 000 of his
own men just marching through what is
then known as the gudrozen desert uh
this like desert area in india so like
he loses about a third of his army
just going back they're not even
fighting anybody they're just like you
know starvation heat exhaustion
dehydration it's like killing them off
so they finally get back to babylon they
have a they have like a big wild party
um alexander drinks a lot
and then he falls ill with a fever
and a few days later he winds up dying
at the ripe old age of 32 in the year
323 bce so my man's man makes an empire
from like egypt to india this huge
empire before he's 32 or before he's 33.
he's 32 at the time when he dies uh he
died just a few days before his birthday
uh poor guy that is so crazy right like
how he like died of a fever i like only
like
after all that murdering and killing in
battlefield walking like he just dies
with fever that's nuts and he drinks a
ton so there's like different accounts
of his death right mt like uh some
people think it's it could have been
like malaria that killed him uh because
no
some people think it could have he could
have been poisoned because like
poisoning was like very popular in
macedonia it was very popular everywhere
all the rage but there's there's some
debate about that because they don't
know if there was like long lasting
poisons at the time because assuming he
was poisoned in his drink and he falls
ill and he's sick for a while and then
dies they don't know if like that type
of poison existed at the time some
people say it did some people say it
doesn't so they don't really know what
killed him they also think that like he
drank apparently he just chugged this
crazy unmixed wine at one point and so
like they don't know if like that's what
killed him who knows but he winds up
dying after you know his this big
conquest in india if he was the avatar
of ahmet right and theoretically she's
able to heal him
is that why he dies now
we could consider that like maybe when
she's locked away in her little stone
figurine does he lose the power you know
kind of like what we see all happen to
mark and stephen when kanchu gets locked
away they no longer can become moon
knight if if this lines up to win uh
ahmed gets locked away is that what
kills alexander like he's no longer safe
from the huge amount of wine he drinks
he doesn't have the healing factor
anymore that would make a lot of sense
and i really like that theory a lot
because like yeah because like as if a
person has all of this super powered um
you know healing ability for like pretty
much his entire life or for a very long
time he's gonna start being becoming
careless and we sort of see that in the
third episode of moon knight but like
you know we see a mark sort of fighting
with less like with more abandon and
just being like all right you know i
could take a stabbing and all that stuff
because yeah i'm gonna live forever
because i'll heal up it's fine it's fine
but like if if someone like alexander
the great who has his power taken away
randomly like maybe if like the gods
like were to put um ahmed into a who
shopped without her avatar knowing he
would be like all right time to drink i
can drink i'm gonna drink all of you and
then uh the worst hangover of all time
death
well and it could line up too that that
like you know it's a plan
by whomever to lock away ahmet but also
have someone poison alexander around the
same times knowing that like without
ahmed's powers he won't be able to heal
up and he'll die
uh without her powers conspiracy i like
a good conspiracy brother conspiracy is
afoot yes it's also maybe maybe he like
maybe they pissed off like the gods of
india right because he's expanding so
far maybe the gods of india get pissed
they come knocking on the overvoid
they're like hi egyptian guys you need
to do something here like ahmed has
empowered this guy and he's taken over
the world and the egyptian guys were
like fine fine we'll put her in a new
shop d we'll get rid of her it's okay
don't
so annoying stop bothering us indian
guys we're just hanging out okay like i
really i hope thor love and thunder
gives us like a look at all the pantheon
i know right it was so cool seeing like
yeah seeing uh
zeus like holding the lightning bolt
like yes
he's like hey i look at all my fans in
the olympia
we're not like that other place asgard
that doesn't exist anymore
those losers um but hey let's talk about
alexander's tomb because what happened
to his body because we see stephen
discover it on moon night but was it
really lost to the sands of time well
the truth is
yeah the final resting place of
alexander the great is one of history's
greatest mysteries and apparently
alexander wanted to be buried at the
temple of zeus amman at siwa oasis as he
considered himself to be the son of the
god and his body was placed in a golden
casket and was on its way to the temple
when it was intercepted by one of his
generals
it's just tall on me ptolemy soder in
his body was taken to memphis instead by
soder and in the late 4th or early 3rd
century bc the body was then moved to
alexandria and over the years the tomb
would be visited by caesar augustus and
even cleopatra who apparently took some
gold from the tomb to finance a war
which is
not a great thing you're going to get
cursed if you're crazy and the dead all
these people visit the tomb all these
famous like rulers visit the tomb and
just like i'll take that thank you so
much honestly
it's a lot of just really expensive [ __ ]
not really doing anything so but these
people already have tons of [ __ ] like
they these are the rulers of countries
like uh and
like caligula caligula shows up at the
tomb and apparently like steals like the
breastplate off of alexander a lot of
this we don't know it's like it's it's
assumed to have happened or like people
claim it throughout history we don't
know how much of it is true but yeah i
just love the idea of all these famous
rulers like paying their respects to
alexander but then also being like i'm
just gonna take a little something for
myself i'm gonna take these nikes real
quick thank you yeah yeah you don't need
this
like imagine like someone like you're
like you someone you know was just
buried with a bunch of ps5s it's like
all right don't touch my ps5s when i'm
dead like no i'm taking a ps5 bro are
you kidding me i can take one of them
you don't need all the ps5 seriously you
don't need all of these ps5s geez once
we get into the ads history seems to
lose track of his final resting place
and by 400 a.d a historian asked to see
the tomb and remarked his tomb even his
own people no not which is you know sort
of like the mcu with no one really
knowing where sen foo or buried um amits
because you know no one knew where
alexander the great was so that was like
he's rolling into town like
hundreds of years after alexander
existed right he's like a smart guy this
was like a
he he was like a religious guy and most
most history at this point is being
written by the church unfortunately
because they're changing a bunch of
things he rolls into town he's like oh i
know all about alexander the great i
would love to see his tomb i know it's
in alexandria he's just going up to
locals and being like where's where's
alexander's tomb and they're like who
the [ __ ] is alexander
i mean alexandria we live in alexandria
and they're like yes it's named after
this guy and they're like i have no clue
who that is i'm just a guy who sells
bread on the street i don't know where
this is what are you talking about
i don't know your friend alexander get
out of here yeah i don't get to get out
of here you want to buy some bread you
don't want to buy bread hit the bread i
know bread jesus christ i don't know i
know bread i know where the bread comes
from
me and since the 1800s over 100 attempts
have been made to identify the location
of the tomb and as recently as 2021
claims have been made on the final
resting place of alexander the great
because last year egyptian officials
claimed to have located the tomb in siwa
the original location alexander wanted
to be buried so could he have made it
there after all
i love this idea mt like this crazy idea
that like he wishes to be buried there
he's like he's dying he's drunk as hell
he's dying he's like make sure
come here come here make sure they bury
me and see what okay
and he dies right
and so they they wrap his body in gold
they're sending him there and then like
you said like ptolemy like takes the
biases generally he's like no we're not
burying him there we're not burying him
in the desert we're gonna put him in
memphis you know we're gonna put him in
a real city uh and then that's where
history gets confused right but i love
the idea that he actually makes it there
and that he's and maybe ptolemy like
pretended like he stole the body so that
people would leave him alone like maybe
that's how much he loved his like former
general or his former leader right yeah
there's all these claims about where the
tomb could be like supposedly in
alexandria and then like there's all
these stories that like you know because
alexandria of course gets ransacked in
the 1300s that like the church takes the
body and thinks it's uh a saint and they
move it somewhere else or that like they
found all these other tombs in the areas
of macedonia that were maybe built
for alexander but he never was put there
or they were built for like some of
alexander's big friends or high-ranking
generals but they're yeah they're still
not sure where his body is they've never
been able to locate the final resting
place of alexander the great who's this
very important person in history and we
have tracked so well i mean we know down
to two days when he was born which i
think is crazy to know that they're able
to figure that much out they're able to
figure out when he died but they just
don't know where his body is and i love
that the moon knight got into that and
having steven find the body and have it
be like perfectly preserved you know
caligula and get his hands all over it
or whatever
cleopatra's not stealing his gold you
know it's there and he and he finds it
right and i love this idea that in real
life it could be where he wanted it to
be originally that would be beautiful of
course they have not been able to verify
that at all
but
it's it's like a fun idea to think about
that ties into it so beautifully the
idea that like this is where i got my
power i was an avatar for ahmed i want
to be buried with her i want to be in
her ancestral land i want to be as close
to her as possible so i love this idea
for marvel to explore that like you know
this is where he was and this was his
final wrestling place and he was being
protected by these scary ass tomb guards
who want to eviscerate you while you're
still alive a little dark but perfectly
befitting alexander the great but we got
to ask the question here is amit the
real reason alexander is known as
alexander the great yeah i think
considering everything we know about the
real history of alexander the great if
we pour all of that over to the marvel
cinematic universe i think it it makes
perfect sense that like ahmed used
alexander as an avatar and he was able
to utilize her power to like take over
the world before the known world before
he's 33 years old like he just he did it
man he he got it done it's in a very
short amount of time to do it in your
20s it's the only way because the 20s
let me tell you it's struggle city he
definitely wasn't paying college loans
in the 20s let's just say that
he was he was pretty much murdering his
cousins in his 20s so
i think that you know it's very much
implied in this episode that you know
he's great because of this power and
because he had this avatar and like all
of this conquest and i really do believe
that especially after this conversation
that um you know a big reason why ahmet
was
um
take put away was because alexander was
this huge
killer yeah she was and she was using
him to maybe take over the world and
maybe get more power yeah herself and
they really emphasized that he was the
the was it the voice of vomit or like
the right the voice of because uh it was
literally in his throat and so if this
is amit's desire and he's almost
speaking on behalf of ahmed who knows
what he's telling all these lands as he
conquers them you know he's like you
gotta you gotta worship mohammed now
but one tomb we do know the location of
is the tomb of the moon god
t-shirt
grab yourself the moon knight latest
obsession shirt from the new rockstars
merch.com store it's called tomb of the
moon god and buying it not only directly
supports us here at dirac stars which
helps us out a lot and we appreciate it
but it also unlocks the ability to get a
shout out in our weekly inside marvel
show with me and eric vos the man
himself so get it before it sells out at
new rockstarsmerch.com because it's not
gonna last forever people i don't want
to hear it i don't want to hear nothing
nothing out of your mouth when the shirt
is gone empty i want to do it
listen i'm sorry i'm sorry my baby but
it's it's gone you you took too long
right you were watching go get your tube
in the boob god shirt now because it's
literally my favorite shirt that we've
ever sold so yes so head up to new
rocksmurch.com today and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help bring
big question to you people like faridy
spring can be a tough time to dress for
because the weather changes so much day
to day luckily faraday makes it way
easier they make the perfect clothes for
all seasons faraday is a family run
brand making high quality timeless
clothing with modern design and
functionality their clothes have the
kind of effortless style you want every
time you go digging around in your
closet i myself just got some items from
ferrati and i really like them i got the
legend sweater shirt which is so comfy
and looks so nice i can wear it casually
i can wear it dress wise i really like
it feels great and i also got some belt
loop all day shorts who doesn't love
shorts shorts weather is coming i gotta
show off these gams you can't see them
on the internet because i won't allow it
but i really do like their clothes and i
can't wait to get more and add their
clothes to my closet faraday's so
confident in the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality they'll replace or fix your
clothes forever no matter what and right
now ferrari is giving all big question
audience members 20
off 20 off
oh my god
head to faritybrand.com
bigquestion and use code bigquestion at
checkout to snag 20
off all your new spring staples that's
code big question at farady
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com slash big question for
twenty percent off again faraday brand
dot com slash big question now brandon
it's time for our bite size questions
delicious
just like a dunkin donuts munchkin now
brandon what would happen if animals
were able to develop the x gene and this
is from tyler edwards on discord thank
you we love all of our discord family
join our discord today yes yes what
would happen if those animals started
mutating well as it turns out we do have
some indication of exactly what would
happen in this scenario in the comics
there have been beings other than humans
that have developed the x gene including
a lot of aliens right like the kree and
skrulls
but that all tracks with the eternals
deviants theories that create mutants on
every planet so maybe that's not exactly
what we're talking about here right that
makes sense
but what about an animal here on earth
getting the x gene well there have been
alternate universes where the dominant
life form on earth wasn't apes for
example on earth one zero zero two
canines developed as the dominant life
form and as such
i wish we got the
we got the adorable rex dogs
who are anthropomorphic dog versions i
gotta see this i gotta you gotta look
this up they're led by professor rex you
gotta be kidding me bro you gotta be
kidding me i love this
a team of good boys a team of good boys
the rex dogs but they're so cute
professor rex is the funniest thing i've
ever heard all day i mean
that was a good day at the marvel
offices when they're like i got a great
idea for a comic guys um
they should have canned the entire x-men
who just done this destroy every other
universe but the re the rex dogs
universe is the only one exactly protect
the rex dog universe at all costs
in the spirit of this question mt should
we be counting multiverses i mean that's
not really what tyler's asking here
right true i mean
he's asking about here on earth what
about a next gene okay there have also
been cases of mutant animals being
created by radioactive material like
they're called mutants but they're not
they're not developed by the x gene for
instance neymar's cousin i think bira uh
he he takes this like radioactive oil
and makes mutant crabs
that are like strong enough to hold
neymar or whatever
but and they're called mutant crabs but
they're not ex-gene mutants they're just
like mutated crabs
[Music]
hey guys and gals we just got through we
just got through spring break i'm sure
you all had a lot of fun but check
yourself for mutant crabs
seriously mutant crabs they'll get you
every time man
you protect your crotch today
mutant crabs they'll get you there's
also been a lot of like mutant spiders
uh that have shown up in like spiderman
comics but again not ex-gene as far as i
could tell not exchange yeah another
instance that's very interesting there
was the nazi scientist fritz von meyer
also known as swarm who discovered like
these bees like a unique hive of bees
that acted unlike any other hive of bees
they were like super intelligent very
aggressive very strong and jerry
seinfeld was in it
it was a b movie it was a b movie for
sure so he's he's experimenting with
these bees and then something goes awry
and they start attacking him and he's
like his consciousness gets bonded with
the swarm of bees and he becomes swarm
he's essentially the swarm of bees
and they're referred to as mutant bees
but i don't i couldn't find out if they
actually had the x gene as bees um
because again there's been like other
multiverses where like we're like you
know the apes have developed the gene or
like insects have developed it but again
that's all multiverse stuff swarm was in
the 616 and these bees were unique bees
but i don't know if they were full stop
x gene b's but i do have a real example
for you mt this is a long way to a ham
sandwich but one of your strongest
examples has got to come from an
encounter that beast had with a humanoid
cat in this story cerebro locates the
presence of a mutant near death hiding
in a barn near the x-men compound one
day so beast goes to investigate and he
finds this creature who attacks him uh
and the creature is like a humanoid cat
right it looks like a human that's kind
of turned into a cat it looks like the
musical cats it's
like the movie cats
yeah it's very frightening
so beast fights back and he like injures
the creature and he feels bad so he
takes it back to the compound so they
can like help it out so he's
investigating it and he thinks he's a
it's a mutant that has like taken a
mutation to become like a cat right
right because like beast himself is like
a beast a beast right yeah yeah he was
experimenting and turned himself into a
beast but he was like oh this is like me
this is something that i've gone through
but gene gray is there and she like
checks out the mind and she's like hold
up a second this ain't no humor that
turned into a cat this is a cat
it's a mutant and has like turned into a
human it's like become a humanoid but
it's a [ __ ] cat it's just a cat and
the reason it's dying is because it's
dying of old age because it's a cat and
cats don't live as long right that is so
sad isn't that sad so beast feels really
bad about it uh and like let's they they
heal it up and they let it go
uh but it's gonna die anyways because
it's just old and he lets it go run away
and die in the woods in peace like a cat
would normally do like a lot of times if
your house cat knows it's sick it wants
to get away and like go die in somewhere
else right
and beast follows it and like buries it
once it dies because he respects it and
he feels a lot of
like connection to it but that it's kind
of fascinating this was a cat that like
mutated and kind of became like a human
so it is possible it can happen um there
is also a very other minor
mutant cat
in marvel comics i don't know why
there's so many mutant cats this
involves like howard the duck a little
bit uh
i know already weird
so there's like the boarding house of
mystery and in it lives this person
named splatter gamora
and he has a mutant cat that has three
heads that can smoke cigarettes that's
all i know about it
what kind of fraternity is this i don't
know
it's it's labeled as a mutant but i
don't i don't know if that one's an
x-gene full-stop mutant either ways but
we do know that there was a mutant cat
it happens so watch out if the mutants
are coming to the mcu we could get
mutant cats uh and we could get cats to
musical within the mcu and it would be
dangerous i want a whole like weird cat
team with goose um this cat uh splatter
gamora's cat oh they're cerberus cat
i want like horus in there too
morris can be on the team also yes
morris too why not not even a cat but
like hey he's just a faceless man i
really i had no idea about that mutant
cat story from the x-men super sad but
also like that sort of technically opens
the door because like now that enemy we
know that animals can sort of mutate
into humans like
i would really love to see like more
mutated humanoid animals like heroes in
the mcu like that'd be really fun and i
and i do believe that you know this is
sort of being implied with you know the
existence of rocket raccoon in the mcu
it's like we do know that rocket was
experimented on and like i'm i'm
thinking that the high evolutionary was
like evolved rocket raccoon from a lower
life form to a raccoon so and the high
evolutionary himself had a race of
animal humanoid people called the new
men which were exactly what you
basically described with this cat um and
so you know we could very much see this
scenario play out in guardians 3
especially with the high evolutionary so
thanks brandon this was a really good uh
good learning that was it was a weird
deep dive for sure brandon another
question for you could you explain for
me the similarities and differences
between plastic man the elongated man
and mr fantastic man and this is from
satan cull on twitter thank you satan
cull i cannot tell my haitian mother
that i thanked you because she would be
very upset yes thank you satan
but thanks satan so here we have like
three very stretchy men right so what
are what are the similarities what are
their differences okay well first the
differences of how they were created
right elongated man he drinks this thing
called a gingold serum to get his powers
he was like he was fascinated with
contortionists and stuff and he goes and
studies these contortionists and sees
that they all drink this weird soda so
he like starts experimenting with the
ingredient in the soda and he gets the
gingold serum he becomes elongated man
then you have mr fantastic who of course
gets the cosmic rays that give him his
abilities and then you have plastic man
who is doused in some unknown chemicals
uh and he also has a gunshot wound at
the time
so the chemicals like get into his
bloodstream and he becomes a plastic man
all three of them can stretch right yeah
all three of them are susceptible to
like heat and extreme heat and extreme
cold but here are the main differences
that really differentiate their powers
elongated man can only be elongated for
a certain amount of time he can't do it
all the time full stop right and he has
limits on how far he can stretch and
what he could do so he's just like
regular men am i right unless you have
blue just like regular man
you can't stay elongated forever brandon
oh boy here we go i was gonna make that
joke that's good
tell that to my wife i can't be
elongated man all day come on
[Laughter]
nice and then of course you have mr
fantastic right who's pretty powerful he
can stretch very thin he can make some
simple yeah he can make some simple
shapes and stuff like that
but then you have plastic man plastic
man diesel is really
really diesel he can make all sorts of
complicated shapes he can make like
machinery he turned himself into a
cannon once you know what i mean he can
make himself a car
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh and it's he's also has survived like
thousands of years he was shattered into
pieces he survived and was able to put
himself back together over thousands of
years batman even once said that he
thinks plastic man is the most powerful
person in the dc universe just because
of how powerful he is
so those are the main differences right
like mr fantastic can't make complicated
machinery and stuff out of himself he's
very smart yes he's much smarter than
plastic man but if we're going by
stretch power like plastic man is way
above mr fantastic who's way up
elongated man so watch out for plastic
man he's a sleeper hit out there
i tell everyone like plastic man is so
underrated in the dc universe because
he's so powerful like like you said
batman regards plastic man has one of
the most powerful people in the dc
universe although rubber band man from
static shock who knows i think uh he may
come in for the crowd just kidding shout
out to rubber band man uh static shock
let's go
sideshow gang um but anyway it's time
for our box of scraps brandon
built in a cave with a box of scraps it
was a box of useless [ __ ]
brandon what personal achievement would
contribute to your legacy of greatness
because we're talking about alexander
the great so what would make you brandon
the great other than you know just being
branded and being great every day
because that's what i mean that's so
sweet of you empty mt what would make
you empty the great i think for me i
mean obviously a lot of people know that
like i'm obsessed with finding uh this
guardians of the galaxy one easter egg
and i have been looking for this egg
publicly like uh on like youtube and
stuff for um
years um since 2016. and i met james
gunn because of it and like he was
really cool and like we got to hang out
because of that so like finding that egg
is like my life's work i want to find it
because like i want to make like a piece
of nerd history that's my main goal
that's the only thing i want is to be
part of that um be like a black
participle from
from
from ready player one but what about you
brandon i believe in umt and you will do
and i will visit your tomb one day and
steal gold from it i promise please do
only brandon's allowed to steal my the
gold from my tune by the way only
brandon my personal legacy of greatness
i think it definitely will get started
uh with my ability to make the perfect
bowl of grits now you might be saying to
yourself oh grits grits grits are easy
to make and i say no i say no unto you
they are difficult to make and i make
the best bowler grits you don't believe
me invite me over for breakfast and i'll
make you some grits that'll blow your
mind it's not easy to do i think this is
just brandon's secret point again gets
you to invite him to breakfast
please someone invited me
someone invite me for the love of
god new rockstars has breakfast every
day we just don't remain fun granted
that'll be so sad
we just never invite brandon to our new
rockstar's breakfast no you would be
there you would be making us grits but
that is it for this episode a big
question thank you guys for joining us
and thank you to brandon for joining me
this episode as always follow him at
grin and barrack and you can follow me
at master team if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet especially here on youtube and
on all your social media platforms and
if you want to continue the conversation
join the new rockstars discord if you're
over 18 and interested just click the
link in the description below and again
thank you guys so much for watching we
love you so much we appreciate the time
that you spend with us and we'll see you
guys next time bye bye
[Music]
you